and reel lost it to Ryan chip to the high
glass Connor Brown is there sets up behind
the net throws one out in front de har retrieves
hands off to kulak that risker got it in on net
by Brown buard to McLoud feathers one to the
right wing Corner get moving to dry cycle nice
pivot behind the net driv side centers Fric
with a terrific save a one time snap coming
in from the point I've known Peter a long time
since he broke in in the Grand Rapids Griffins
of the American Hockey League and he's tracked
Tupac really well and made a couple good saves
Oilers control in the offensive zone rist
shot got save morazzi but he couldn't hold
on to the rebound another try for brown
by Jared son Ori through the skates of
Reichel the and kulok come together McDavid a
stick lift shot by G on shoulder save is made
by Skinner Magna acoss to Tori and there's
one down low that's taken away by De har and
now counter McDavid with speed McDavid on the
backand to the forehand Sam morzac and he gets
the rebound denying Kane backto back Saves
by morzac he's been tremendous in the early
going a take away by Dickinson
across the line with Anderson a
tow drag shoots score Dickinson picks
the corner and the BL had the early
lead Place him at the All-Star game that's a
career high 14th goal for Dickinson a puck one
by Dickinson in the neutral zone I don't think
he would have when scoring first are the most
in the NHL so even when they score first they
struggle but they've got a much better chance
Sanford moves in wrap around try spring his
Skinner to pin his glove up against the Left
Post and keep the puck out of the net and
now we have our first Gathering of the
night what a great play the Chicago Wolves he
wraps around the back of the net Skinner has
to battle to get there in his Donado has the
puck right in the crease you can see the puck
never crosses the line as and they did review the
Sanford wraparound and the Donado crash and did
confirm no goal moving in is dy score Leon trial
finds the back of the Chicago net and just like
that we are tied at one seven goals in the last
nine games now from Ryan McLoud but this starts
back on the Oilers breakout good play on the
wall by Fogle and nurse will get it up to McLoud
McLoud who is a was thought to be the Oilers
number three Center coming into the year was
moved onto the wing in New York on the road take
makes it to the half W back to eom forced forward
handled by Conor Brown down to the goal line out
in front sweeping out of his Fogo Deni by morzin
enjoy all right ARA thanks very much finally
a Faceoff win for the Blackhawks and a short
handed short side he'll reverse it
to bleck ble nearly lost it and did
to McDavid that shot Sav mazic as
he robbed Bard a terrific takeaway
nen Hopkins can't exit the zone out in front
Anderson puts it on net robbed by Skinner the
Oilers have turned the puck a couple of times
just inside the line This Time n kicked ahead
kurashev tries to work his way around CCE wraps
it around the wall waiting for it radish back
to kurv on the Move sweeps one on net and a
pad save was made by Skinner there's a drive
through traffic by Tori that was was blocked
before it got through CC an outlet and now
Drive Sidle through Center across the Chicago
line tenori took the puck right off his stick
Evan buar protects it from the for check of kurf
KF nearly took it away moved all the way around to
Echo ahead moving in shoot scar terrific pass
Echo finds McDavid and and just like that the
Oilers have the lead back counter McDavid all
alone in front Off the Bench is just going to
stand up at the far Blue Line look at that
com's taken two shoulder checks already the
Blackhawks are changing he knows mcdavid's there
and this is no chance for Peter morzac that pass
is a bullet it's right on the tape and in his
last eight games against the Blackhawks Conor
McDavid has got 17 points Point face off one
back to eeko point to point it goes a drop
pass newon Hopkins puts on the brakes he Bard a
drive SC he does it again Conor McDavid but they
wave this one offer's coaches are discussing
this on the bench whether to look at this or
not they're looking at it from their video
room as Heyman gets in behind Magna and you
can see he's all wrapped up with morzak it hits
morzak right on the 34 of his right shoulder and
they won't challenge this there's too much contact
between Heyman there's no goal in the play to Goen
interference blassic centering past Donado
that shot just missed the glove side of
Skinner Murphy gets a return on that pass save
made by Skinner can't control the rebound and
whistle shoots sprawling left his Skinner
like a tourist for 20 minutes two shots on
goal now the Blackhawks seering him just
prior to and on this power play Donado is
fighting for the puck and as he keeps it
alive Skinner's got to read the play get
across Michel free heals and puts it
back up top back to Reel kinsky with
room shoots that the flex just one between
the legs and opportunity on the doorstep
for pitlick tries again save made in the
blue paint Skinner couldn't control the
rebound Ken Away by nurse AR nurse tries
to reverse it denied by Donado tries the
opposite side and hoists one all the way down
to the Chicago Blue Line nice find moving in
one touch score McDavid the hman set up
by ddal Tick Tac Toe it's a 3-1 lead for
Edmonson as dry Sidle gets ahead of the play
mcdavid's in the far corner he attacks this
all the way way up the ice he was in the
to the left of Stu Skinner when this play
started McDavid looks up across the ice or
rather dry cidal looks up across the ice
to find McDavid and a step in front of lassic
correct and typically they deem possession if
you're kicking it to yourself that's possession uh
control control does not need to be on your stick
blade after the chall have determined that the
play was offside there is no goal please reset
theame a hockey night here on ESP and plus from
Chicago Edmonton struggling that shot at H be Iron
BR pitlick had it on his stick with a yawning
net and missed to keep the game 2-1 after the
Hawks had almost tied it radish to pitlick off
the goal post and we move on in Period three
Amin and it escapes of De
har nicely controlled right
down Broadway centering pass Hamlin
into the glove of mazic Ernie set up
Hamblin Peter moric makes a remarkable stop
on James Hamlin across Vander Kane out of the
box five aside no shots on on that power play
for the Hawks Center ring pass save made by
Skinner just as we get back to five aside we've
seen Skinner make about a half a dozen of these
saves Kane's late get it's dealt with by Skinner
puts it behind the net 3 seconds 2 one there's
vasic there's the horn and Edmonton will escape
with two points but they had to earn it tonight